hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 american science fiction and action
movie called outside the wire
in 2036 a civil war between russian
insurgents led by a criminal warlord
called victor koval and local
resistances in ukraine erupted u.s
troops are stationed as peacekeepers on
this lawless new frontier on their first
operation american soldiers supported by
robotic soldiers called gump are
ambushed by the insurgents they are
outnumbered cornered and the gumps can
be destroyed easily
while the field soldiers are struggling
to escape lieutenant harp a drone pilot
spots an unidentified vehicle coming
towards the soldiers and reports it to
miller considering it as a threat he
asks permission to launch a missile but
is rejected by miller as two of his men
are still trapped harp then asks his
partner bale to confirm the airstrike
with captain bryden but the request is
rejected as well
however harp disobeys his superiors and
single-handedly launches the missile
towards the vehicle because of that two
of miller's men can't be saved causing
miller enraged despite the fact that he
manages to save the other 38 soldiers
his act of disobeying a direct order
causes him to be sent to camp nathaniel
the u.s military base in ukraine
upon his arrival herp meets colonel
eckhart who reminds him that if he
survives from the mission he will be
sent back to the air force but if he
dies his story will be a caution to
other pilots to not disobey and break
the rules he then arrives at a building
where gumps are being charged
harp finally meets captain leo who will
be his superior in camp nathaniel leo
reveals harp's outstanding record in the
military and exposes harp's plan to
marry soon
leo immediately gives harp a mission
ordering him to assist the captain to
deliver vaccines to a clinic where there
is an outbreak of cholera after signing
the agreement leo tells a story about
victor koval who is responsible for a
bomb in ukraine that killed more than 25
000 people he adds that victor is
planning to get to systema perimeter
where russian's nuclear bomb is kept and
will use it to kill a lot of people
thus leo assigns the pilot an additional
mission which is to hunt victor while
preparing herp is very surprised by the
fact that captain leo is actually an
android super soldier before departing
the captain reveals that he purposely
chose harp because he thinks the boy
could think outside the box
suddenly harp is confronted by miller
and his men punishing him for killing
two of his soldiers previously but that
doesn't last long as the captain comes
and they depart to the clinic on their
way harp shows his girl's picture to his
superior and turns out that the robot
soldier still has some sense of humor
installed within him
their journey is delayed when they find
an air truck was hit and blocked the
road the civilians are unhappy with the
army and throw them with stuff
one of them hits the gump causing it to
shoot the thrower instantly the
situation starts to heat up but leo
manages to calm the civilians down after
negotiating with their leader
unfortunately the army is ambushed by
victor's men and they engage in a
gunfight the insurgents are prepared as
they can eliminate the gumps easily
because of this leo and harp have to
travel and deliver the vaccines on foot
while miller and his soldiers remain
behind to hold victor's men
on their way leo tells harp that the
pentagon designs his face in that way
because his face conveys neutrality
which makes people calm
they arrive at the refugee camp and head
over directly to the clinic while
handing over the vaccines to the doctor
a sniper ordered by victor attempts to
assassinate leo and harp but misses and
hits the nurse and doctor instead the
captain manages to one-shot the sniper
and interrogates him forcing him to tell
victor's location but he refuses to
answer and eventually tortured by the
local people
harp questions leo's decision for not
reporting the situation to the base but
leo says they don't have enough time to
do that and they continue their journey
to hunt victor
in the truck leo explains that he has
the ability to break rules in certain
circumstances allowing him to act of his
own volition
they then meet sophia the resistance
leader who informs leo about high
classified access codes to launch the
nuclear missiles that are hidden in a
place nearby
they realize that victor is going after
the codes and they have to prevent him
sophia tells them to find an arm dealer
who knows the location of the codes
before they go the men buy several
weapons from her which she claims that
the money will be used to pay the
orphanage
sophia escorts them to the market and
find ashlock his men try to attack leo
but he manages to eliminate them easily
the arm dealer attempts to run away but
is chased and eventually captured by leo
left with no option ashlock leaks the
code's location which is in the bank
nearby
they immediately head over to the bank
while sophia kills the armed dealer for
being a traitor
upon arrival the captain orders harp to
cut out a tracker from his body so that
he won't be detected by the russians
believing that victor is inside the bank
they immediately go in leo tells harp to
call eckhart
after that leo engages in a gunfight
with victor's man while harp tries to
help the hostages to escape
a few moments later a killer robot
appears and attempts to kill leo thanks
to their teamwork they together manage
to destroy the robot lill continues to
find victor in the code while harp
finally calls eckhart requesting backup
the rookie brings the hostages out
however he is confused when he discovers
that eckhart sends gumps instead of
human soldiers
not long after the russians come out
from the bank and threaten to kill the
hostages a gump then shoots one of them
causing a gunfight between them harp
tries to protect the remaining hostages
and brings them to a safer place harp
calls the colonel back only to find out
that he is actually sending a drone and
is going to destroy the entire place
with a missile on the other side leo
spots a man who is trying to run away
after taking the codes
he shoots him but the insurgent still
manages to run away after a long chase
leo eventually captures him and
retrieves the code
unfortunately the man is not victor back
to harp the missile is launched
destroying the entire bank
at this point eckhart believes that both
leo and victor have been killed by the
missile
the men regroup again and drive away
from there on their way harp is
suspicious of leo's real motives and
questions what he's really up to
the captain then reveals that he has
been manipulating harp all this time
forcing him to commit an improper
decisions because the android backup
system allows him to relinquish the need
for human authority if the person is
exhibiting poor judgments
because of that harp is now unable to
give command to him anymore after that
he knocks harp unconscious and leaves
him on the side of the road where he is
picked up by sophia's men
leo goes to meet with victor himself
revealing that both of them have been
working together all this time victor
refuses to give the location of the
perimeter where the nuclear missile is
being kept and leo has no option but to
kill him he eliminates all victor's man
and eventually impales victor to death
he then acquires the location and
immediately heads there
on the other side sophia reveals u.s
hidden intentions in the peacekeeping
mission to harp the pilot finally
realizes that leo is going to launch the
missile on the us
sophia releases him and harp rushes back
to the base
he then reveals everything he knows
about leo to eckhart and miller telling
them that he is still alive and heading
to the missile location
they believe him and harp immediately
calls bale to locate leo she finds him
but he is in disputed territory on the
russian border where it is impossible
for the colonel to deploy an army there
harp then offers himself to go after him
alone
before he departs miller gives him a
weapon that is effective against leo he
eventually arrives at the silo where the
bomb is kept and sneaks in while leo is
setting up the device and installs it to
the missile
harp arrives at the room but
unfortunately is spotted by leo who
strangles him until he falls unconscious
leo continues the installation and the
countdown begins herp awakens and
ruthlessly shoots his captain with the
given weapon until he falls down
it manages to break leo's body the
android finally reveals his real plan
saying that he wants to attack america
in order to shut down the ai or cyborg
program that created him he plans to do
this to prevent the country from
fighting more such destructive wars in
the future because the robot soldiers
such as gumps are the face of never
ending war
after that harp reports back to the base
and gives a green light to launch the
airstrike the silo and the nuclear
missile are completely destroyed but
harp somehow manages to escape from
there and on his way back to base
at the end of the movie eckhart will
send him back to the air force and tell
him that he is a hero
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching